[Music]
how do you manage a cattle herd
numbering in the thousands this is a
question every Rancher wants an answer
to raising and managing a large herd of
cattle is no easy task and is incredibly
costly to address this challenge some
cattle ranchers have come up with a bold
yet highly effective solution managing
cattle from the
[Music]
air using helicopters to gather cattle
has become a common practice at Large
Scale Farms across Australia a country
with a total cattle population of 29.9
million about 372 Mi Southwest of Darwin
Australia during the morning Rush an
Australian family gathers cattle by
helicopter today's challenge is to
coordinate around 1,500 cattle which the
helicopter will drive to the designated
Gathering Point cattle herds in South
Australia are substantial in scale
ranchers there work year round to gather
roughly 81,000 cattle on their 1.3
million acre property the feeling of
piloting a helicopter while directing an
immense herd of cattle is unlike
anything else it's a combination of
technique and Instinct in the past it
might have taken 20 men to gather cattle
at a musty yard a process that could
last up to 3 days now one helicopter can
complete the job in just half a day
helicopter mastering has revolutionized
Australia's beef industry enabling it to
keep up with massive Global demand for
cattle meat there are over 28 million
cattle raised across the US in the
American West the majority of these
cattle are free range managing such
large numbers of free ranging cattle
across thousands of acres of land is no
simple task as it is both time consuming
and labor intensive traditional hurting
methods like horseback riding have lost
much of their effectiveness Farmers
spend countless hours moving cattle
between grazing areas monitoring each
animal and ensuring none stray or get
injured to address these challenges
American Ranchers have begun using
helicopters as a tool to manage free
range cattle over time they've seen
numerous benefits from this approach
first helicopters can cover vast
expanses of land in a short amount of
time they are extremely useful for
monitoring cattle across challenging
terrains this includes Hills forests or
Wetlands from the aerial perspective
American ranchers gain a comprehensive
view of the tracking herd's condition
and guiding them towards specific
grazing zones helicopters equipped with
GPS technology allow Farmers to observe
and anticipate potential issues this
also helps them to keep cattle from
straying too far or preventing certain
animals from wandering away from the
herd Additionally the aerial view helps
Farmers identify any cattle showing
unusual symptoms early detection can
prevent disease spread within the herd
and ensure a timely Veterinary Care for
any sick animals in areas with limited
grazing land Farmers must rotate herds
between different pastures often using
trucks as the primary method they load
cattle onto specially designed trucks to
ensure safety and minimize stress during
Transit before each flight Farmers
refuel and conduct thorough helicopter
inspections this is an important step to
minimize risks when flying
the sound of the helicopter's engine
cuts through the quiet of the planes
from above the entire herd is visible
numbering in the thousands they graze
peacefully scattered across valleys and
Hills some might argue that using
helicopters in ranching is costly due to
the substantial initial investment
however with a one-time investment
ranchers can use helicopters for years
reducing labor costs and realizing
long-term profits moreover the ability
to quickly and accurately managed cattle
herds ensures healthier livestock this
leads to better quality meat and milk
products increasing Farm
profitability during the grazing season
ranchers must Round Up cattle that have
wandered across hundreds of Acres a
major Challenge from above Pilots can
easily spot the herds but it's not that
simple they face animals that try to
hide anywhere they can ducking under
trees or running along river banks the
lapse in the Pilot's Focus can be fatal
numerous people have lost their lives in
helicopter accidents another difficulty
comes from harsh weather strong winds
can make helicopter control more
dangerous than ever sometimes
helicopters must fly low to avoid winds
dense foliage and rugged Hills the
safety of the pilot is Paramount more
important than catching cattle trying to
escape farmers can return and gather
them at another time with skilled flying
the pilot must maneuver so that the
cattle Don't Panic while moving in the
right direction the helicopter circles
gradually lowering and swooping close to
the ground to herd cattle into
designated areas ground crew in pickup
trucks follow behind gradually steering
the cattle towards the Gathering Point
helicopters have enabled Farmers to
carry out large-scale livestock
operations with confidence cattle is
spread across vast areas to fatten up
for Asian beef export markets Farmers
also use helicopters to rescue cattle
trapped in hard to reach areas like
marshes high mountains or dense forests
in Switzerland 12 cattle were airlifted
down a mountain after being injured on
an Alpine pasture once lowered staff
checked their health conditions these
are short aerial rescue flights Rescuers
use Nets to keep the animals safe during
the ascent the cattle hangs suspended
beneath the helicopter by a long
cable countries like Australia and in
some parts of the US are also using
drone technology to manage cattle herds
especially in vast areas where
traditional hurting methods are timec
consuming and less effective drones are
programmed to fly at specific altitudes
and speeds to guide cattle in a certain
direction after locating the herd the
Drone approaches the noise and movements
of the Drone startle the cattle causing
them to move away making it easier for
Farmers to direct them towards grazing
zones or
enclosures in addition to hering cattle
Farmers also use drones to monitor crops
this method is applied to pastures and
grain fields to ensure a year round food
supply for the livestock farmers can
easily observe their fields from a
comprehensive aerial perspective
allowing them to identify any cron
issues particularly during the grow in
season before pest damage the crops
drones equipped with high resolution
cameras and sensors can help farmers
detect
infestations the realtime Imaging and
coverage provided by drones also allows
Farmers to inspect irrigation systems
thermal sensors can reveal if fields are
too wet or too dry enabling them to
adjust irrigation accordingly this
ensures optimal water supply
in California drones are also used to
protect farms and cattle from predators
this is by aiding in hunting activities
before initiating a hunt farmers can use
drones to get an overview of their land
or locate potential Predators once the
target position is identified farmers
can move into this area to hunt this
method makes hunting more efficient
while increasing success
[Music]
when we think of Central Asia we often
picture vast grasslands where herds of
cattle roam freely however Behind These
images lies a booming cattle industry
bringing both economic and cultural
value to the region the cattle farming
and trading markets in Central Asia are
dominated by countries such as
Kazakhstan usbekistan and K
who are the major
producers these nations are developing
specialized areas to optimize beef
production while also improving the
quality of meat and dairy
products the people have maintained a
nomatic hurting system for thousands of
years families still practice free range
hurting where cattle move seasonally
across natural pastures this meth method
allows the cattle to graze on nutrient
rich land while taking advantage of
nature with minimal labor costs in
addition they raise strong local cattle
breeds these cattle are not only
resilient to the arid climate but also
provide valuable meat and wool offering
good profits for
herders for farmers in the kastan
Republic cattle farming is a vital
source of income over the past 20 years
the number of cattle in the country has
increased by
60% although this growth has boosted the
economy for many farmers it has also
contributed to the degradation of
grasslands the people of Central Asia
are adopting modern livestock farming
techniques at many modern Farms farmers
use sensor systems and software to
monitor the health weight and
productivity of each animal this helps
to optimize the farming process
minimizing disease risks and improving
product quality the shift from
traditional hering to Modern feed lot
methods combined with technology such as
temperature control bance and optimized
nutrition has brought significant
economic
benefits Central Asia is not only known
for its resilient native cattle breeds
capable of withstanding harsh climates
but also for developing important hybrid
breeds these hybrid cattle offer higher
meat yields and tender nutrient Rich
meat meeting the growing demands of the
international market beef from Central
Asia is distinguished by its bright red
color and evenly distributed marbling
making it more appealing on dining
tables in Russia and China in Kyan the
famous kako livestock Market is one of
the most active places for trading
cattle here buyers can directly inspect
the appearance and behavior of the Cales
they often check the coat skin teeth and
legs to assess the Cal's Health some
buyers request that the Cales be led
outside to observe their movement and
reactions this helps them to evaluate
whether the calves have any issues with
their legs or nervous systems once a
deal is reached the exchange of cash
takes place right at the market the
calves are then transported to the farm
to begin their new Journey calves need
their mother's milk during the first few
weeks of life to develop healthily
Farmers collect milk and feed the calves
using specialized bottles or tubes after
a few weeks of milk feeding the cars
begin to transition to soft foods such
as hay and small
grains Farmers often prepare separate
shelters for carves especially during
the first few days to protect them from
the cold as their immune systems are
still
[Music]
weak in the summer when the Grass Grows
abundantly Farmers Harvest hay to store
his feed for the cattle during winter
the hay is either cut manually or by
machines and then left to to dry for
several days Under the Sun to retain its
nutrients once the hay is dry Farmers
collect and store it in large storage
facilities or barns near the cattle
shelters this ensures they have enough
feed for the cattle throughout the
winter when natural pastures are no
longer viable as winter approaches and
the weather becomes harsher with
temperatures dropping significantly
farmers bring their herds into shelters
to protect them from the cold winds and
snowstorms these shelters are typically
built with insulated walls to withstand
the cold the stored hay becomes the
primary source of food for the cattle
over winter ensuring that they receive
enough nutrition many farmers also
supplement the hay with grains or
additional feed such as sugar beets and
oats to boost the cattle's immunity
during the colder months
the grasslands of Central Asia span
millions of hectares providing a vast
natural resource for cattle farming
these grasslands are mostly found in
arid steps or Highland regions where the
harsh climate is well suited for cattle
growth thanks to the climate shift from
warm in the spring to hot and dry in the
summer the grasslands regenerate and
grow steadily during the summer the
herds are moved to high higher cooler
Mountain pastures to escape the heat in
the winter when temperatures drop canala
move to lower pastures or shelters to
protect them from the harsh
cold hybrid cattle breeds can produce up
to 18 L of milk a day in contrast to the
seven or 8 lers typically produced by
local breeds on small traditional Farms
hand milking is still common farmers use
metal buckets to collect the milk on
larger Farms milking machines are
increasingly used improving efficiency
and ensuring hygiene freshly milked milk
is usually filtered and stored in cool
containers or large tanks if
Refrigeration isn't available the milk
is typically used immediately to avoid
spoilage the milk may be left for a few
hours to sour slightly and then gently
warmed to around 30 to 40° C to prepare
for
coagulation to ensure a continuous and
stable Supply dairy farms need to be
located near populated areas and trading
hubs however in more remote areas Farms
specialized in beef rely on longer
intermediatory chains because beef does
not need to be consumed immediately and
can be stored in cold storage or export
ordered cattle farms in remote regions
don't face significant challenges in
supplying meat to large cities or
exporting them to the neighboring
countries the demand for antibiotic free
and growth hormone free meat is rapidly
growing organic livestock farms in
Central Asia are capitalizing on this
trend to supply high quality
environmentally friendly meat that
aligns with International
preferences once the cattle are fully
grown and healthy Farmers sell them to
slaughter houses or larger livestock
Farms most of the beef is delivered to
butcher stalls at local food markets
meeting the demand for fresh beef among
the local
population thanks to Natural grazing and
frequent movement the beef has a firm
muscle structure while remaining tender
making it suitable for various cooking
methods additionally large cattle
markets in Central Asia are where locals
and Traders gather to buy and sell
cattle in bulk serving both domestic
needs and Export
[Music]
demands Central Asia has become a major
beef supplier for countries like Russia
China and many other markets beef raised
on natural pastures is highly valued for
its quality thanks to the Natural Gra
methods and grass-based
nutrition Central Asian countries not
only raise indigenous cattle breeds but
also crossbreed them with high yield
varieties to increase productivity and
meat quality the process of raising
trading and processing Livestock in
Central Asia reflects not only economic
development but also a harmonious blend
of traditional and modern methods new
farming models and diverse processed
products have helped Central Asia
establish its role on the global meat
export map
[Music]